hey guys Ryan right here don't make a
fight as a cookie just now I was gonna
watch The Legend of Zelda Wii gameplay
demo but I've already seen this so I'm
gonna have one very good looking gamer
and one not so good looking gamer who
goes by the name of ELISA fill in for me
let's do this
hey guys ELISA be crazy this is my
crotch ah I'm dead cyber what are you
doing over there gonna watch the Zelda
Wii U gameplay trailer oh yeah and like
stabbing myself silently because I saw
it was up and I couldn't watch it
because I was probably gonna watch it
here so I was like sitting there like
okay so today why don't we show a
glimpse of how the new Zelda game is
shaping up its aren't you yeah and it
looks like it's sunset already so we
must be looking to the west right I
wanted everyone to see how beautiful
this scene is with the Setting Sun John
yes since this is a client world we're
making a number of high places that
offer great news so now you could decide
where to go through from here right you
can see so far beautiful this is a good
place to look around from and if you see
say a suspicious-looking tower in the
distance you might decide to head there
right and then you saw the flash there
whoa you said a new type of pika
yes and now the course also marked on
the map oh my god Traverse you can also
zoom in through here you can take a very
long time to world anyway we try to go
to the point that me marked on a map
right played an important role in
Skyward Sword it would be a bit hard to
reach our destination on
but luckily here we have a horse yeah
what I'm gonna see finally this is a
densely wooded area yes I'm hardly
touching the control stick we're not
touching it
yeah and I won't hit any trees real
horses don't run into trees very often
good point
well that seems natural we're working on
details like that and now that your
hands are three you can do a variety of
things on the works yes you can really
change the camera angle for example
Wow and you can swing a sword like
normal and arrows go to a place where
deny knowing that enemies with these
arrows
there's insect and animal life as well I
saw apples growing here the last time
yeah you can pick any what ya a bit
suspicious
we must be near a dungeon hmm places
like this I knew a tenant to run into
these guys mom hello everyone there hi
numb all right no I heard a metallic
scent that sound tells you that your
arrow has hit the right spot in damage
jumping you can shoot arrows I see it
Zelda bullet time so how far away is our
destination in here for 5 minutes more
you sure to be released next year yes
all the staff members are working
together and doing their best by the way
mr. Miyamoto how about your starfox I
asked me that now oh that's good news
Star Fox will arrive before the Legend
of Zelda next year oh why is the game
bed is really starting to feel good no
but before that comes out will release
Majora's Mask right Euler
made a number of adjustments majorities
and then that feels pretty good on three
yes that's taken ten years but the three
day system is intact and it's so
accessible you can even play while
chatting like this thank you for
watching cuz they like teasing us this
is huge like these little things like
not running in the trees it's gonna be
so much better like if you guys haven't
played Zelda before go back and play
like Ocarina of Time or Twilight
Princess and it's go to great games
you'll have so much fun but those little
things like running into trees will bog
use like you won't even see the size of
its enormous little bull that's not even
a word to Skyrim it seems like they're
combining aspects of not Skyrim and like
specifically but in general that style
of gaming into the Zelda realm and I am
so excited if you look back at the
original Zelda
they basically plopped you down in the
middle of a giant field giant for the
NES time yeah and said go and that's
what you did you just went you can't
tell what you're doing you just kind of
do until you find something going back
to that where it's like I mean with the
60 Delta 64 they kind of had that
because of the limits of the system and
everything you know like you had Hyrule
Field as kind of a hub and then each
would branch out to things because
that's all that's only but it could
handle you know got a little bigger got
a little bigger and then Skyward Sword
shrank it down which was real
weird yeah and now it's back to where it
needs to be exactly and you know what I
you like about it still is you can set
the beacons also there you know what
you're playing a game and you try to run
off something or into something you get
blocked by invisible walls you're like
what is this it seems like they don't
have those batteries you can jump off of
what ever you so desired so far let's
hope there's gonna be one spot that we
can't kill I hope I said it seems it's
an app did ya get 5 out of 5
get out then for us you undo your vice
you guys we love you if you haven't seen
us before you should subscribe to our
channels idealistic be crazy that's
awesome
my that cyber channel it's got stuff on
it she was on it we're doing five
minutes of phrase two and it's painful
sucks it's really also real rejects
don't forget subscribe this channel
because I got you I tried my best
so anyway subscriber three things that
you should click and you should shout
outs this is a delicious cookie I give a
shout-out to this delicious cookie dough
serves where I go to facebook.com slash
the real rejects and hey you know what I
have a shout out I'll give a shout out
to the jiggle gels Oh jiggly jelly
you deserve a shout out cuz you're
awesome and you're dedicated subscriber
to not only the real rejects but to
everybody involved and we love you we
really do like just know that